good morning believe nation today's
messages don't repeat your mistakes over
to you dick smith I made every mistake
you could ever muster ever make but the
interesting thing was that I never make
the mistake twice I remember every
mistake when I opened the first dick
Smith's shop after 10 minutes no
customers came so I jumped into the car
and drove along military road at mosman
on the north side to try and drum up
some business from the car trade
business because I sold car radios and
when I got back to my little premises I
had one employee and he said dick I've
just sold an l-3 lockdown car aerial and
he'd sold it for five dollars and he
said we've made a dollar fifty and I
said no we've lost a dollar fifty
because i hadn't priced marked it that
second i went out and i got little tags
and i put a price mark on everything you
could fit a price on and from that day
on it was well known as dick smith
electronics got 250 shops 50 million
turnover that you would get the sack if
you were near a product that didn't have
a price marker on it and I'm rather
proud of that because that was an early
mistake that could have cost me a dollar
fifty it it's all of these things that
you learn from I really love this
message but I want to take it a little
bit deeper for you guys with two
thoughts my first is that a lot of times
you don't know what the real mistake is
if it's an obvious mistake then that's
easy to fix to say well I'm never going
to do that next time but sometimes you
don't really know what the right mistake
is and how to take corrective action so
as an example maybe you decide I'm going
to grow my team and I'm going to hire
somebody to help me out and then that
person doesn't work out well the mistake
might be your hiring process sucked or
you weren't a great manager or you know
the next time you need to do better
screening or you need to do trial
project first before you work with them
again but you might internalize them and
say I can't work with anybody i'm going
to be a lone wolf for the rest of my
life right and that doesn't help you
accomplish the mission that you're on
doesn't help you accomplish the dream
business that you want to build and how
the impact
you want to have and so when you make a
mistake it's how do you know what the
mistake is and then what the corrective
action should be sometimes it's really
obvious other times it might need a
little bit more thinking because there's
so many entrepreneurs who then do the
wrong thing after making a mistake the
second thing is then having an awareness
two of the mistakes that you make
subconsciously and I think because of
limiting beliefs that that you've grown
up with and that you tell yourself that
hold you back in your business you're
making tons of mistakes every day and
you don't even realize it right if it's
something obvious and it's something
that you can fix but there's a lot of
mistakes you're making without even
knowing it because you have a broken
mind set I remember one that I've talked
about in channel when I was younger was
I always felt like I was too young to be
able to sell software the people who
were three times my age and I phd's and
I'm not a scientist I'm trying to sell
scientific software the mistake wasn't
in not calling it was not believing in
myself enough right in thinking that I
was too young and and I did just I never
caught it until much later because it
was just so subconscious that I kept
making these mistakes over and over and
over and over again I never caught it so
I never improved and never got better
and it took a while before I did
eventually pick up on it and so it's
having the awareness that you're making
the mistake as well and that can be
where one having people around you to
help point out mistakes can help for me
when I find super helpful is modeling
success and looking up to big
entrepreneurs and musicians and actors
and innovators in politicians who've
done their part to change the world and
seeing how they act and looking at that
to think of well how can I learn from
them and what am i doing that is not
quite at that level yet and every time I
do that I find some kind of limited
belief that i have that as soon as you
get awareness of it that's the first
step to solving the problem and so yes
you never want to try to make the same
mistake twice but just make sure you
take the right action after making that
mistake
and then try to tap into your
subconscious to figure out the mindsets
and limiting beliefs that are holding
you in place so that you can make
corrective action and build the business
of your dreams so the question today
today is I want to know what mistakes
you are making on an ongoing basis leave
it in the comments below I'm going to
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso